erevan en ébullition ce jeudi le coeur
de la capitale arménienne est scindé en
deux place de la république les
partisans de nikol pashinian venus en
nombre soutenir le premier ministre d'un
pas décidé mégaphone à la main et à
moins d'un kilomètre de la place de la
liberté
l'opposition qui appellent à la
démission du chef du gouvernement
à l'origine de cette crise politique la
lourde défaite militaire contre
l'azerbaïdjan 2 novembre dernier vécu
comme une humiliation nationale depuis
la fin du conflit au haut karabagh le
chef du gouvernement est sur la sellette
les manifestations se multiplient
organisées par l'opposition
désormais rejointe par l'armée hier
nikol pashinian a limogé le chef
d'état-major des armées ce qui a
exacerbé les tensions
entouré de ses partisans ce jeudi le
premier ministre a appelé l'armée à ne
pas intervenir dans le processus
politique du pays
certains veulent entraîner l'armée dans
des processus inconstitutionnelle il
s'agit d'une tentative de coup d'état
mais le peuple ne permettra pas un coup
d'état militaire en arménie du côté de
l'opposition les manifestants se rendent
vers l'assemblée nationale se préparant
à installer des chapiteaux il appelle à
occuper l'espace public jusqu'à la
démission de nikol pashinian le parti
arménie prospère de l'homme d'affaires
gagic sa rue piat a lancé un appel au
premier ministre
la déclaration de l'armée est un
tournant nous appelons nikol pashinian à
ne pas à mener le pays vers une guerre
civile et une effusion de sang
pashinian a encore une chance de partir
sans trouble côté diplomatique la crise
politique est surveillée de près en
particulier par la russie et la turquie
qui se disputent l'influencent dans la
région du caucase du sud
le kremlin espérant de son côté un
règlement pacifique du conflit
nous suivons avec inquiétude l'évolution
de la situation en arménie
nous estimons que c'est une situation
exclusivement intérieure aux pays alliés
très proche et important pour nous dans
le caucase
nous appelons au calme le président
russe s'est entretenu au téléphone avec
nikol pashinian vladimir poutine qui a
appelé à un règlement de la situation
dans le cadre légal mais a aussi exhorté
chacune des parties à la retenue
[Applaudissements]